hello everyone and welcome to today's
webinar implementation of a high
throughput
waste water stars cov2 detection method
providing actionable data to your county
or your campus i'm susie valdez of
labyrinth and i'll be your moderator for
today's event
today's educational web seminar is
presented by the lab roots
and brought to you by saris nanosciences
to learn more
visit them at sarisnano.com now we
encourage you to participate today by
submitting any questions you might have
during the presentation
to do so simply type them into the ask a
question box
and click send we'll answer as many
questions as we have time for
at the end of the presentation you may
also submit any technical issues here as
well
if you have any trouble seeing or
hearing this presentation
now would like to welcome our speaker dr
smirty
karthik kion a postdoctoral research
associate from university of california
san diego
dr carthy kian you may now begin
your presentation welcome
thank you susie um hi everyone i hope
you've all been having a
good day so far um to just a little bit
of introduction about myself
my name is smithy kartiken i am a
postdoctoral
researcher in rob knight's lab at uc san
diego
and at uc san diego we have been working
on a multi-faceted approach
for um stars cov2 surveillance um where
we conduct diagnostic tests in tandem
with in
large scale environmental surveillance
source kovi to
infection dynamics as well before i dive
into the technical aspects
of the talk i just want to give a quick
introduction
or a brief overview as to why
we chose to look at wastewater based
epidemiology for starskoli2 in the first
place
so first cle2 like a lot of other
coronaviruses
can be shed in the stools of patients
who are infected
with thirst cov2 so whether you're
pre-symptomatic
asymptomatic or symptomatic you will
very likely set
the virus in your stool if you're
infected
the issue here is a lot of people who
are presymptomatic or asymptomatic
are actually not going to know if they
even have the infection
and by the time they develop symptoms
some may not at all
and go and get tested they would have
already spread
the infection unknowingly to a lot of
people so by the time a person
develops an infection and goes and gets
tested there's a good at least
one week lag by when you know that the
person is positive
so in order to eliminate that lag we
start looking at wastewater because
even before you show symptoms you're
shedding it in your stool
so if you start looking at wastewater we
would get a better idea of how many
people in an area are actually infected
and this not only helps to keep up with
the low testing rates but it's also much
cheaper
than having to test large populations at
a time
so here at ucsd
we have a three-pronged approach at
looking at
the wastewater for source cov2 so
in we do sewage testing on the ucsd
campus
we also look at the wastewater from
a couple of school districts elementary
schools
where there are young children who are
attending school on a daily basis
and we call that program sassy are safer
at school early alert system
and on a larger scale we're also looking
at the entire
san diego county and we're looking at
their wastewater treatment plant there's
only one wastewater treatment plant for
san diego
and so far this has been slightly
updated as of today we've processed over
15 000
wastewater samples just from campus over
1200 samples from the school districts
in san diego and over 200
samples from the san diego wastewater
treatment plant
so the reason we started off
the reason we started off for
san diego county testing was mainly
because if you
notice on the top left corner these were
the case load per day in just san diego
county
so we uh when we when the pandemic first
hit
san diego county especially was not
doing nearly enough testing
and they were only testing the
symptomatic cases but by now we know a
lot of asymptomatic people can just as
much spread the virus
so that point only symptomatic people
were getting tested there was no
widespread asymptomatic testing so we
still
did not know what the true pandemic toll
was at that point
so we started testing um the wastewater
from july so at that point it looked
like a big peak but
now in hindsight july was maybe just a
tiny blimp
so at that point we were recording just
probably 100 or
a couple hundred cases a day but i did
speak we were recording nearly
4 500 to 5 000 cases every day
so we started sampling from the
beginning here and we're still sampling
from point loma least water treatment
plant now
um san diego is right here which is um
the southern almost southernmost point
of california and
here is the u.s mexico border that you
can see
so in order to test the san diego
county's wastewater treatment plant we
went to the only
wastewater treatment plant that serves
all of san diego and it's almost two and
a half million residents
so all of the two and a half million
residents
wastewater essentially ends up at the
wastewater treatment plant
the picture you see on the right it is
called the point loma wastewater
treatment plant it
has one step of wastewater treatment and
then it discharges
the treated effluent into the ocean that
you see here
we sampled here every day and this is a
pretty large plant it processes
175 million gallons per day of
wastewater
so here essentially you will see the
map of the same of the san diego county
and all of those lines that you see in
purple are essentially the sewer lines
and all of these sewer lines essentially
connect to the point loma wastewater
treatment plant that's right
here and the circles the differently
sized circles are essentially the case
load
in that zip code so and they're adjusted
for population as you see towards the
south this is the border and we have a
higher proportion of cases from these
zip code compared to the north
but by the end of the day all of these
get discharged to the pointless water
treatment plant
so when we first started looking at
wastewater for surgical v2
we wanted to try out pretty much all the
methods available
for trying to concentrate the virus from
wastewater
so unfortunately unlike clinical samples
or nasal swabs we cannot directly
extract the rna
for starch cov2 and then look at the pcr
this is mainly because
it is super dilute and you also have a
lot of solids and other junk
in wastewater essentially anything that
people flush down the drain is going to
come up
in your wastewater sample and
unfortunately the signal might be too
weak
and we might have to concentrate the
virus initially before we can actually
even see
if there is any source cov2 in there so
far this is the biggest
hurdle when it comes to analyzing
starsky b2 and wastewater because
the vital concentration is expensive
it's time consuming
and it might take like a person hours to
go through one sample
and it will take a long time for us to
process a few samples a day
and we can do more than maybe 10 or 20
samples a day
assuming you work all day so in order to
look at why this was an issue we tried
looking at the typically used
concentration methods for wastewater
so a few of them are shown these are the
most commonly used methods for
concentrating the virus
from wastewater so one of them is you
use
uh filter vacuum filtration units to
filter out where
you expect the virus to absorb to your
filter vapor and then you extract the
rna from there
the others are centrifugation and ultra
filtration based approaches
and peg precipitation which is
polyethylene glycol-based precipitation
is also another commonly used method
but right off the bat you can see these
are very time consuming and they're also
expensive and the number of raw
materials you need for each
when you're doing 20 samples today it's
not a big deal it's okay
you can still manage but if you're doing
200 samples a day
it cannot scale up for instance we tried
all of these methods and
we started with filtration it used to
take me
six to eight hours to filter just 50 to
100 ml
of wastewater at a time and this is near
impossible
if i have to do 200 samples a day so
because of all these bottlenecks we look
towards some other procedures where we
can
first automate them make them cheaper
and then maybe
we wouldn't have to hire like 50
different people to process our samples
so in order to do that we looked at the
nanotrap particles
we mainly looked at it because um we
we've wanted to see if you could
automate this entire procedure make it
hands-free
so we wouldn't have to babysit the whole
process or the protocol
and we could process hundreds of samples
in one day
so in order to do that we took raw
through it we did not fall for do any
sort of pre-processing because that
again is another bottleneck and we don't
have
the that kind of time or resources to do
that for many samples
so we took our raw sewage samples
and then we added the nanotrial
particles so the nanodrop particles are
essentially magnetic beads that
specifically bind
to viral particles and then to separate
these
viral particles from the rest of the
junk in wastewater we use an equipment
called
a kingfisher the kingfisher is
traditionally used
for cell biology or rna and other
extraction methods not specifically for
sewage
but the cool thing about the kingfisher
is it has a magnetic head
so we decided we wanted to try
using that liquid handling robot to see
if that would do the concentration and
the extraction for us
since the nanotria particles are
magnetic based
the magnetic head was able to pull
the viral particles which are attached
to the magnet thereby leaving all the
junk behind it
so this way we're getting a more clean
and concentrated version of the viral
sample
by discarding all the craft that we
don't need so once we
have that sample we were able to do the
rna extraction on the same
kingfisher robot and then we did the rtq
pcr
for screening for genes that are
specific to source code 2.
to give you a better idea of what this
process looks like so
what you see here on the left most is
the kingfisher
liquid handling robot so you see the
magnetic head that goes
up and down and homogenizes the sample
and picks up just the
good part in this case which is the
circuit virus from the
wastewater sample and the pic the video
you see in the middle is the same
kingfisher
that is able to do the extraction of 96
wastewater samples
at a given time so this process
can extract the rna from 96 samples in
about 36 minutes
and the concentration step which
normally takes can take like six to
eight hours
for just a couple of samples is reduced
to 45 minutes
on the kingfisher and it can take 24
samples at the same time
and process about 24 samples in 45
minutes so
just optimizing the simple concentration
extraction step we already have a 100
fold reduction in time
and finally we also do the qpcr plating
using an ep motion which is another
liquid handling robot
so you can see that in the right most
corner so
what ep motion essentially does is it
does the plating for the master mix
and also plates the samples that you get
from the kingfisher which are extracted
rna
and puts it along with the master makes
for qpcr
so it can process 384 samples in 20
minutes
so this saves us a lot of time and
effort
and energy in trying to pipe it out
really small volumes
of master mixes into 384 well plates i
have done that manually as well and it's
not
a pleasant job and there's no way i can
do 384 samples in 20 minutes
so essentially this is this was a huge
time saver for us
and once we decided we had a protocol
that could process hundreds of samples a
day
we took all of the samples from our
point loma based water treatment plant
and process it to this protocol
but in order to make sure that this
protocol was sensitive
so the main difference in this protocol
was it only took 10 mil of wastewater
compared to
a lot more wastewater input that you
needed for the other protocol
this could do with just 10 ml would
significantly save those costs
and our consumable cost for
a sample was maybe 13 to 15
for example compared to we used to spend
much more per sample
we already make sure that this protocol
which is much faster
was comparable to the traditionally used
protocols
we had to we had to run some tests to
see
if this was just as good if not better
so in order to do that we used actual
first kobe 2 vital particles that we got
from our collaborators at the bsl3 lab
so we spiked in a dilution series of the
actual first coe2 viral particles
into the wastewater and then we did
three different concentration methods
one of it is the one i just showed you
the other one is the peg or polyethylene
glycol based
precipitation method the other one is
filtration
for all for all samples which were run
through three different methods we got
the highest recoveries when we actually
use
the high throughput method or the
nanotrap method
we feel that it's probably because
there's less variation since a robot is
doing the extraction
compared to manual extraction which can
vary depending on the lab tech or the
person who's handling the samples
the other thing we found was the results
were highly reproducible
and our replicas were very close to each
other in terms of results and we didn't
see too much of a standard deviation
when we ran
multiple replicas so here this plot just
shows our standard curve when we
put known amount of virus into our
samples we did
nine full serial dilutions and four
replicates were used
per um sample dilution and we got
pretty good recoveries when we used the
high throughput methods as well
and the last plot on the right just
shows the difference in c2 values
for the same sample that was run with
three different methods
we use the high throughput method we got
one of the lowest cq values
the lower the cq values the more
sensitive or the higher the viral load
so this gave us confidence in using this
high throughput approach for all our
samples so using this
we ran all of our point loma or san
diego county's wastewater treatment
plant samples
using this method and the plot on the
left
shows the viral load we saw from
wastewater on a daily basis
and which is shown in orange and the
other
plot that is shown in blue shows the
number of cases
san diego county was reporting on a
daily basis
we found a very good correlation between
the viral load we see
in the wastewater compared to how many
uh infections were recorded in the
county on a daily basis
with one major caveat that we saw this
trend at least five to six days ahead
in the wastewater compared to what we
saw in the actual
san diego counties um report this could
be because
a person is still shedding before they
get tested and also there are delays in
testing and
at that point we were not having nearly
enough testing rates compared to how
as the infection rates were in southern
california
so this gave us a good confidence that
we could probably use
wastewater to as an early alert system
to tell us
how the next few weeks are going to be
are the cases going to go
up or are the cases going to go down
this also gives
public health enough time to do any
interventions or focus
testing on certain regions or increase
or decrease testing based on what the
wastewater load is showing us
so we wanted to use this data not only
to see the trends
but we also wanted to see if we could
forecast
into the future how the trends were
going to be
so we wanted to see okay one week from
now where we still don't have the
wastewater data yet
will the cases be going up or will they
be coming down or are they going to be
staying stable
so in order to do that we wanted to
build a predictive model
which takes the wastewater data and it
also takes the day of the week
so the day of the week was included in
our model creation mainly because um the
county sometimes if there was the
weekend
they didn't process as many samples and
suddenly they would process all of these
backlog
samples on monday so we would get a
weird spike on monday but that's mainly
because
their testing rates lagged over the week
or long holidays
so we wanted to also take into account
the discrepancies that that might have
and we also took the new number of
positive cases to build a model
so we use the first two months data as a
to build a training data set and then
use that to see if he can predict into
the future
so the plot shown here shows the actual
um caseload that san diego county
reported on a daily basis which is shown
in blue what is shown in yellow is what
our model predicted
would be the case load on that
particular day give or take
a few and then what is shown in red
towards the end
shows what our model is forecasting
into the future up to three weeks on how
the case load is going to go whether
it's going to go up or down
so we found that the model was able to
give extremely
accurate data for at least one week into
the future
the accuracy came down slightly for the
second week and third week which is
expected
but we felt that this gives at least a
good seven days head start to see how
your county is going to be doing so as
you can see the red coincides with the
blue
pretty nicely even for one week into the
future
so this gave us confidence that we could
probably use
wastewater data for um looking at how
the
infection dynamics in the community are
but
this has its own disadvantages in a
sense because
san diego zombie is a large county so
like i said um
point loma is taking the waste from
nearly 2.3 million residents so it's
obviously um you know catering to a
large population
we wanted to see if we can use the same
principle
but on a smaller population if let's say
we have 10 buildings can we
check the wastewater of 10 different
buildings and then
just ask the people to test for the
buildings where we see a positive signal
but in order to do that we have to know
if maybe you know is one building's
wastewater signal enough
for us to pick up let's say that
building has 500 people
but we think only one person in that 500
people building is infected
we wanted to know if that one-person
signal is enough
for us to detect in wastewater so in
order to do that
we use the hospital building on campus
so ucsd's
hospital called jacobs medical center is
in our la jolla campus
the building is shown here this hospital
was actually treating
covet patients from the beginning of the
pandemic so we installed a wastewater
sampler
right outside this building and we have
the patient data
for the number of patients admitted for
kodi in this building on a daily basis
so we compared that to what we were
seeing
in our wastewater signal and from when
we started
the hospital had anywhere from two
patients to
26 patients in the three-month period so
we did this
every day for 12 weeks and the caseload
for people who were infected in the
hospital were anywhere from two to
twenty six
and every single day we were able to get
uh seroscope to a viral signal
in the wastewater and then we also were
able to look
at the stool samples of the infected
patients
to also compare to see how many of them
were actually shedding the virus in
their stool compared to how much we were
getting
in the wastewater and we actually found
a pretty good correlation between the
case flow and the wastewater signal
which shows that at least we can use
this data semi-quantitatively
because the peaks correspond well to the
peaks and wastewater so at least we know
that even if there are two people
infected in a really large hospital
building we're still able to pick up
that signal
so this gave us confidence to move on to
our campus surveillance so the reason
ucsd
had to have a campus surveillance was
because like a lot of other universities
that
was closed completely during the fall
term
ucsd actually had nearly 11 000 students
who lived
on campus during the fall term
and we had over 4 000 employees who
worked on a daily basis on campus
so when you have nearly 11 000 or 10 000
students living on campus every day
it's very hard to ensure the safety
unless you test these people every
single day
which is a really expensive endeavor if
you have to test 10 000 students
on campus every single day so this is
why
um ucfd turns towards wastewater
as an indicator to see whether they
needed to test
more people or not and we used
wastewater mainly because
this would give the university admin an
idea of
which areas or which buildings they
needed to focus testing on
instead of testing every single person
on campus
so in order to do that we had to cover
as many of the campus buildings as
possible
so when we started this program we
started off only with the residence
units or the residential
dorms where the students were saying so
we have undergrads graduate and family
housing all
of which were on campus and when we
started
we had about 68 auto samplers so the
pictures you see
are pictures of the auto sampler which
were connected to the manholes which you
see on the right most
and here and these auto samplers were
programmed to collect
wastewater from these manholes which are
at the outlets of all these residence
buildings
at regular intervals of time and every
day we used to take these bottles back
to our lab and do the analysis
so when we started we have over 240
residential buildings on campus
so we use 68 auto samplers to cover all
of these buildings
we have since expanded the program to
cover over 350
buildings which are residents as well as
non-residence buildings on campus
we expanded this to non-residence
buildings on campus because ucsd
increased the
number of people authorized to work on
campus to 50 capacity now
so we have a lot more people working on
campus on a daily basis
so in addition to this we put a couple
of auto samplers and isolation dorms
isolation dorms are just two large
buildings on campus designated for
people
who test positive to quarantine and
people who travel international students
who travel will also have to quarantine
for 10 days to two weeks in the
isolation arms before they can test
again and go to their actual residences
so the way we put our samplers are so
this is a google map image of ucsd
campus
you see it's a pretty large campus and
all these
yellow dots that you see light up are
the locations
of the wastewater auto samplers on
campus so
all of these buildings are covered
essentially by
a couple of auto samplers so we have not
left any building not covered
so just by looks at it you can see it's
a pretty spread out campus
and um it took a lot of effort to
identify the right buildings and cover
the entirety of the campus so
the building that you see right here is
crips institute of oceanography which is
also a part of
ucsd which is slightly a little bit off
campus but
it's still a part of campus so we
covered all of these areas with auto
samplers
so this snapshot just shows the auto
samplers concentrated on residence
buildings
so all these um orange circles you see
are the auto samplers that are specific
to the residence buildings
similar to campus our residence
buildings are also very spread apart
and they're not very close together so
we had to get near complete coverage
of all of these residences on campus
the way we chose which buildings
get samplers was based on the occupancy
data
so this snapshot is just a zoomed in
version of one of the resident
complexes on campus so this
area is just graduate and family housing
so each green block you see is actually
a building
and all of these aso numbers are
basically
unique sample codes for the auto
samplers so the reason this area
has a lot of autosamplers is because of
the occupancy for instance
just this one building here had over 450
students living in there so
with one building that had that many
students we had to get one sampler in
that building because
if it was positive you had to test 400
students
but if you see the bottom we only had
one
auto sampler for five six buildings this
is because the occupancy of these
buildings were slightly lower so it was
just probably 200.
so since it was lesser we put one
autosampler carving two or three
buildings
so this way we ensure that we covered
all of the campus with wastewater auto
samplers
and to make this logistically possible
we divided how the samplers were into
routes
and then we had a team we had seven
routes so
each route was covered by one person on
a golf cart picking up
all of the wastewater samples from that
area per day
so it takes roughly one hour for one
person to finish one route
so this was an everyday process so every
day we used to get samples from all
these
samplers or volunteers who used to bring
up samples
so the way we collected these samples
were
we have a mobile app where we could
directly scan the samples that are
coming into our lab so we don't have to
keep going back and forth and linking
the samples because there might be a lot
of room for error
and we don't want to inform the wrong
building of a positive
because of a simple human error so on
the left you see
our auto sampler one of the auto
samplers on campus with a unique barcode
on the right you see a sample bottle
with another unique barcode
so we change this barcode every day so
the person who's collecting the sample
all they do is they take
this app on their mobile phone which is
shown in the middle
all they do is they open the app the
camera on their phone will scan
both barcodes so once both barcodes are
scanned
our backend database automatically links
all of this data
to the building data so we know which
buildings drain into this particular
manhole which is picked up by this
sampler
so this essentially eliminates all of
the other work that we would need to do
in the middle to link the data back and
forth
since this is already pre-loaded so the
person just scans and that's it once
that person scans
it updates on our database saying that
this area has been this
sample has been picked up and scanned
into our system
so once that's done all of these samples
are brought to
our lab which is on ucsd campus as well
so this is how our daily date looks
between nine to ten thirty or
in the first hour two we get all of our
sampler
all of the wastewater samples in the lab
and it takes us
about an hour or two to concentrate
these samples and the rna extraction is
pretty straightforward
um that's probably the shortest step and
our rtq pcr
is another two to three hours just the
rtq pcr run takes about an hour 45
the plating takes about 20 minutes so
this way
we're able to process all 100 plus
samples
within five hours of when we get the
sample
so the main reason we needed this
turnaround was because the campus wanted
a quick method to send out notices
so they wanted data on the same day only
then they could make decisions on whom
to test
and whom to quarantine and whom to
isolate if this data comes three days
later
by then the infection might have spread
we don't know the dynamics so
it the time was really essential for us
especially because of the number of
people who are on campus
and the number of people come to campus
on a daily basis
and this was also coinciding with the
peak
um in the san diego county where our
positivity rates were
were pretty high as well so at that
point
um the earlier we got the data the
better
so um using this data
we had to make sure we had an automated
reporting system because
we only have two blob techs or two of us
who used to process all the sample in
the beginning it was just
me and another undergrad who used to
process all of these samples every day
so we wanted to see if you could
automate the data reporting system
because if we manually had to go link
the qpcr data to which building
it would take us a long time and you
know there's also room for error
so in order to simplify that we came up
with an automated workflow
so the first part of this just involves
sample collection
so the person goes to the sampler picks
up the sample scans the sample barcode
and then brings it to the lab for
analysis so the sample
once the sample barcode is scanned it
automatically links it to a database
which already has the data on the
building name the building occupancy how
many people are there in that building
and who should be notified if there's a
positive so once we have that
we know whom to inform so in the lab
side of things once we process the rtq
pcr or
pcr data gets updated into like a google
spreadsheet
which is how it looks here so what you
see on the left
is essentially how the lab data looks
like so the sample id is just a unique
id per sample
and on the right if you see a red
it means that that sampler was positive
if you see a number inside the red box
it is the average cq or cycle threshold
value
of detection inside that if
you see a blue it means that the sample
was negative from that building
if you see a white it means that that
auto sampler did not pick up a sample
that day
either due to a clog or low flow or some
mechanical issues which
we fix and what you see in yellow just
means
it's an isolation dorm so we expect the
signal to be positive because we do know
there are people who are infected who
are quarantining or isolating there
so what you see on the left is how our
lab data looks which is a very simple
spreadsheet
the automation that i showed you on the
previous slide will take this data and
automatically convert it to the public
facing dashboard which you see on the
right
so what you see on the right is what the
public
or the ucsd students or anyone
who wants to view it will see they won't
see any of the backend they won't see
any of this
excel sheets all they will see is an
interactive map
and in that map they can just move and
click on the building
to see if that building was positive
that they or if it was negative that day
it not only shows that it'll also show
if that sample
was not picked up that day if that
building is monitored if it's not
monitored and there's also a slider on
the top
that you can see which shows the data
which shows the calendar
so if a person wants to see how this
building
was maybe a week before today they can
always move the slider
and then see okay so this building was
positive today but it was not positive
yesterday
so this is an interactive dashboard
which is open to the public so any of
you
will also be able to access the
dashboard and see it
and this gets updated on a daily basis
so using this data people can see if
they're building if there was a
if there was a positive wastewater
associated with that building
and if so how long was the wastewater
positive for that building
then using this data we want we
use it to notify which of the students
should go get tested
so what you see on the left is sort of a
before and right as an actor
so this was when the cases in san diego
county were peaking which was january we
were recording like 4 000 cases a day
as you can see this was how our
spreadsheet looked we had
so many reds which means so many of our
samplers were
picking up wastewater positives but this
is more recent
march april where you can see a lot more
greens showing that there were very few
positives
and this also mirrored our diagnostic
data where our positivity
decreased to less than one percent in
the spring term in spite of
10 000 students living on campus so
throughout our surveillance program our
positivity rates have been less than one
percent in spite
of the surrounding county having a 15
positivity rate so the way we got this
to work was
um every time we see a positive signal
we send out localized notifications so
if only that building was positive only
the residents of that
building will get an email
notification saying you have to undergo
testing because you saw a pause
positive if that building had no
wastewater positive
there wouldn't be any notification to
those buildings so we only send it to
the buildings that we see a positive
and then we monitor to see if we
identify the positive if you identify
the positive we see
if that person was moved to the
isolation housing
if that person is moved to the isolation
housing we see
if the wastewater is still positive if
the wastewater is still positive it
means there's one more or
maybe more than one person um who's
still in the building who can be
contributing to the signal
so we repeat the messaging again so all
of our dorms
have a vending machine that you see on
the right with self swaps
so these vending machines will just have
a self-test nasal covered swabs so the
person once they get a notification
we'll just go to the bottom of their
building
swipe their id and then get a self-test
sample from the vending machine swap
themselves and put it in the dropbox
that's right next to it
they use their mobile phone to scan
their barcode so they're so they will be
notified of their test within a day
so all of these samples from the dropbox
are tested every day
so this way the student does not have to
make an appointment go stand in line to
get tested and they can just go to the
vending machine at the bottom of their
building and get tested
which saves um a lot of time and
personnel
in testing as well so using
this system we've detected
we were able to detect 85 of all
diagnosed cases early as a result of the
wastewater signal
so because of this um all of the campus
diagnostics were driven by wastewater
and in order to see if
us sending a notification would increase
testing of students on campus we we
checked
all of the buildings we sent positives
to see how many people were taking up
testing as a result of our notification
we found in all cases there were at
least a 2x to sometimes even 39x
increase in testing uptake
after we sent a wastewater notification
so all these spikes you see
are the number of student tests we get
as soon as we send
a wastewater notification most likely
they test within one day
sometimes you'll see a peak after two
days meaning that you know they got
tested within two days
but all in all we found that in two days
we're able to identify and isolate most
of these cases
as a result of which it did not have
enough time to spread
or increase our positivity rates on
campus
so like i mentioned earlier we were also
looking
at our isolation dorms every day
so here the first picture you will see
um where our isolation dorms are located
as019
is a sampler that is right outside one
of our isolation dorm spell
darm buildings and es017 is slightly
downstream
so the downstream sampler is just to
evaluate to see if we can pick up that
signal
even away from the building or sit close
so
through our study we found that these
two samplers were
consistently positive which makes sense
because you know we
know that there are people in there who
are tested positive
in order to see if we can get a link
between the number of people
who are in the building to how much
viral load we're getting
in the wastewater we compared the
wastewater viral load to the number of
people who are positive
in the isolation dorm we had this data
on a daily basis we knew on a daily
basis how many of them
came in how many went out and how many
were staying in
and using this data we were able to find
a pretty good
link to the trends so all of our peaks
matched up showing that the wastewater
data is really good at picking up peaks
even on a smaller scale we know on a
large scale it can do that but this
shows even on a smaller building level
scale we're able to get some sort of
um a handle on how these um
signals correspond so using this data
we are trying to actually see if you can
do any data analytics and predictive
models to show
if some areas with historical data will
have a higher risk
of getting more positive than some other
buildings on campus
this is done by taking historic
wastewater and the
diagnostic data to see if there are some
areas or on campus or some resident
storms which have
higher positives than some other dorms
which have been consistently negative
so this will help us focus
testing on those areas and see if they
could be hot spots before they actually
become bad enough for us to not be able
to do much
so this way we prevented any outbreaks
from happening on campus for the last
six to eight months
so this is the end of our campus part of
it
the last section of it is our
san diego county school district pilot
program
so as a part of our elementary school
program we chose
15 schools in the san diego county
so these schools are specifically chosen
based on their
income levels the positivity rates in
those areas
and some of these uh schools were very
close to the border so they had a high
migrant refugee population and their
testing update rates were so low
so in order to still ensure that these
schools were
able to operate safely we picked 15 of
those schools and offered
free diagnostic as well as environmental
surveillance program
so that this was a program that started
by the
san diego county and they contracted
ucsd to run the program for them
so when we chose these schools and we
did daily wastewater monitoring in these
schools
we also did surface swaps where we
swapped high touch surfaces
like doorknobs like desks and these high
test surfaces
in these schools and the other thing was
we chose these schools also
based on the occupancy of these schools
these schools were operating at near
full capacity
during the pandemic and the positivity
rates in these zip codes were upwards of
25
so we also did weekly diagnostic testing
for all of the staff the teachers as
well as the students
in the program and we did diagnostic
testing because we wanted to validate
our
environmental testing with diagnostic
testing to see
if we missed any samples that were not
picked up
so on the right you see one of our auto
samplers in one of these elementary
schools which the
students put stickers and drew and
personalized
and on the left you see a map of all the
schools that are currently enrolled in
our pilot program
and as you can see they're very
diverse and they're split all over the
san diego county
just slightly more focused near the
water because the
prevalence rates there were higher but
their testing rates were lower
and currently we're using this data to
see if you can prevent outbreaks on
schools and so far none of these schools
in spite of operating at full capacity
have had
significant outbreaks because of the
constant
monitoring and surveillance and
this brings me to the last portion of
this talk and also it shows us which
direction we're heading currently
so while using rtq pcr is a good uh
method to track source code e2 cases
um viral genome sequencing will help us
to actually see which are the strains in
circulation are there any variants of
concern
are there multiple people contributing
to the waste stream or is it just one
person
so in order to do that we'll have to
look at the viral genome sequence from
wastewater
and it's much easier to look at it from
wastewater because
sam like um sequencing one wastewater
sample is
essentially getting the sequences of
every single person in that building who
might be infected compared to a nasal
swab where one person is
equal to just one strain so what we're
doing now is
we are doing moral genome sequencing
using
a tiled amplicon approach to get the
whole genome from wastewater
and in the right you will see snapshots
of some of her
phylogeny so the one i've highlighted in
green
shows the wastewater samples viral
genome sequence
and you can see it's identical to
another sequence and that other sequence
was actually sequenced
from the nasal swab of a person who
tested positive
and was in the same building whose
wastewater we tested
so this gives us more confidence in
using wastewater
as a monitoring tool for tracking
variants
especially when you have a lot of
variance of concerns circulating
so based on our analysis so far we've
processed about 400
samples and we're going to be processing
about 2 000 more
over the next month and from our point
loma point loma is our san diego
county's wastewater treatment plant
from the wastewater that we survey every
day these are all the lineages we
detected
we do see a few variants of concern and
these are samples that they're dated up
till april
so we're still processing the may and
june samples now
the sassy is the school elementary
school program and these are all the
variants that we're seeing from
wastewater
wastewater samples from the same schools
as you can see
there are a couple of variants of
concern and we saw b117
um or the alpha variant or the uk
variant
much ahead of when we saw it in the
diagnostic samples actually
so with that um i want to conclude the
talk
um but i also want to thank all the
people who made
this um whole program happen it's a
multidisciplinary effort
and without all of these people and
their help you wouldn't have been able
to
set up and scale and successfully
operate a program like this for the last
eight months
and with that i'm done i will be happy
to take any questions if you all have
any
thank you so much dr carthy can for that
informative presentation
and we will now start that live q a
portion
of the webinar and if you have any
questions you'd like to ask please do so
now
just click on that ask a question box
located on the far
left of your screen and we'll answer as
many questions as we have time for
and dr can it looks like we already have
some
incredible questions coming in from our
audience numbers
our first question is
for your figure comparing peg
nano trap and membrane filtration
methods
were they the same volume sample
yes they were the same volume of the
sample um initially we did do
50 but when we did direct head on head
comparison we kept the same volume
we started off with 50 for all and then
we brought it down to 10.
thank you so much have you published the
protocol
for extracting rna with magnetic beads
yes um i we do have it in protocols.io
our entire sampling to analysis protocol
is published along with our standard
curves in protocols.i
oh i will be i can link i can add the
link to it if needed
thank you so much and i want to thank
our audience for these great questions
coming
in now our next question from an
audience member
if the wells in the plate accepted by
the kingfisher can only
accept 2ml how did
you extract 10 milliliters of raw sewage
um the 24 well head ma we use the 24
well plates which can take 10 ml
the 96 plates can only take two but we
for the concentration part we use a 24
raw head and a magnet
which can take much more for the
extraction we use 96.
thank you and did you measure any
physical or chemical parameters
in your samples like turbidity or ph
um for the county wastewater samples yes
they measure total dissolved solids they
measured all of that
but for campus we did not mainly because
we
um our campus samples are very upstream
so we expect a lot more solids because
we're capturing it right as they flush
so in that case we did not measure
these extra parameters mainly because
our samples are homogenized we don't
pre-filter so we homogenize our sample
and we take the solid and liquid
together
so we don't um bias ours towards you
know
the supernatant versus the solid
thank you so much our next audience
member wants to know and this is a
two-part question
as covet-19 infection rates continue to
drop
assay's sensitivity is going to be
increasingly
important can you comment on the ldod
achieved using the nanotrap
pre-concentration method
versus ha filtration or other approaches
that utilize
larger starting sample volumes and
second part
do you think this level of sensitivity
will be
sufficient when the infection rate drops
below one percent um that is a great
question
and yes uh ironic what we found was
contrary to popular belief at the lower
volume we used we actually got a better
um sensitivity essay with nanotrap so we
ran
so far we've run about nearly 18 000
samples
and we at least on campus we have not
missed a single case
because of sensitivity and we used this
mainly because
um it was a closed system and we knew
exactly how many infections were there
because when we started our program we
met in the first month we mandated every
every student on campus to undergo
asymptomatic testing
so we could validate our wastewater
assays
with the diagnostic so and in the
beginning every week all
of the students had to undergo
asymptomatic testing so that gave us
us you know a good handle on sensitivity
however um when we first did the
comparison we did a lot of benchmarking
we do not use a surrogate unfortunately
like bovine or any of the other
um surrogate virus particles we use
directly source cov2 viral particles
instead of using a surrogate for our
recoveries
we also use the same high throughput
method to estimate
um viral concentrations from the tijuana
river the imperial beach
the estuaries where the concentrations
are extremely dilute
but we are still able to detect
first-clovitoviral signal from
the nanotrap which we were not able to
when we filtered half a liter
using ha filtration and the other thing
we found was when we used the other
methods
our end goal with sequencing so we were
not able to get sequences out of
our other methods mainly because of
maybe rna fragmentation
this is just a guess on my part so i
don't know if that's the reason
but so far when we use our nanotrap all
of our sequences
gave us near complete genome coverage up
to 99
even for cq values of 37.
so um my best estimate is when we even
when we have low prevalence we would
have seen in
all of these samples we processed uh if
we had missed any because our initial
test we
initially used aha and peg for about two
months for our campus samples
before um you know we switched to this
and we did extensive benchmarking
so i'm pretty confident at least from
what we've seen so far
we have not missed any we've picked up
like one asymptomatic case in a building
of 650 so
and we've also been able to pick up from
the beat samples and our effluent
samples so we think
we don't see it as an issue we did start
nanotrap with 50ml because the
manufacturer recommended us to use 50
before bringing it to 10. so we did 50
40
30 20 10 before settling on 10 and we
did not find any significant difference
but this again could be biased because
the kingfisher homogenizes the sample
better
than we do we don't do any bead beading
in our
extraction protocol as well so we did do
full meta transcriptomics as as well as
shotgun metagenomics and all our samples
to see
um if we could also detect you know the
virus that way or what
other communities were able to pick up
and we found that without beat beating
we're still
able to get a decent enough community
analysis
in terms of startup school v2 so that's
um yes that's i hope it answers but if
you have
more questions i can go into more
details too
thank you so much now our next audience
member wants to know
if you could comment on the least water
that you are testing
um in what way exactly
specifically what white waste water are
you testing
with the question oh um we're testing
san diego county's wastewater we're
testing the campus
wastewater samples and
we're also doing tijuana river the
imperial beach and other
water bodies are in and around
san diego county at this moment thank
you so much
we'll have time for a few more questions
would you be willing to
partner with other labs to ship samples
for validation purposes
um samples as in wastewater samples or
extracted samples
for testing out it will help
it doesn't say but maybe that audience
member will
send another question in and we'll have
that i'm sorry
i'm pretty sure like we do we um
re-aliquot all of the samples
that we've extracted we don't store our
wastewater
actual raw sample for more than a day
because um we do not heat inactivate our
any of our samples and we get 150
samples a day
ehs does not want us to store the raw
samples
but if we could if it's like a couple of
samples we could store them at 4c
but we do have all of our extracted rna
from when we first started processing
about 20 000 samples
we've stored all of them so we could
definitely send an aliquot for
you know benchmarking or validation if
needed
wonderful and that audience member just
wrote back in and said waste
water samples is the clarification for
that
um we could but we typically don't our
whole time is 24 hours for wastewater
samples because we process the same day
maybe 48 hours but if it's one or two
samples that we need to send i'm pretty
sure we
could wonderful thank you so much now
do you sequence the same rna
that comes off the kingfisher or do you
have to do any further cleaning or
processing
before sequencing um we
typically don't so our samples we use a
miniaturized swift protocol
to do our sequencing i think it probably
already has like
it has an amperage bead cleanup step
but we don't do anything specific for
waste water that we don't do for other
clinical samples so it goes
uh in the same pipeline as our clinical
samples on campus
so it does have an amputee or beat
cleanup but we we
don't do anything specific just for
wastewater because we
all our um kingfisher protocol already
has a bead cleanup which is magnetic
bead based already
thank you so much our next audience
member says
how many of your samples are above cq 30
and what is the successful rate of those
samples
for sequencing um almost
all our samples are over 30 and we have
a 97
sequence success rate so far um
initially when we started
um we used the arctic protocol um
christine anderson of the scripps lab um
used to do it for us and they had a hard
cutoff of 30 saying anything over 30
will not sequence but unfortunately 99
of our sample for over 30. um but
i think the difference we saw is um
supposedly it extracts intact viral
particles as opposed to fragments so
we've been
we've we've gone all the way to 37.12
with the highest cq we've gone now
we sequence every single positive we're
getting on campus
campus as well as um the county because
the county wants to sequence all of the
samples we get from point loma the
prevalence rates are lower right now so
our cqs are definitely in the 30s we do
get
we used to get a lot in the 20s before
from campus but with low rates we're
getting all of ours are in the 30s
our lods close to 38 is hitting our lod
but all of our sequence all of our
samples um over 30 sequence successfully
we get 95 to 99
coverage for all of them we don't
consider our
bioinformatics pipeline flags any
sequence below 75 is not passing qc so
unless we get like a 75 to 80
coverage it gets flagged as not passing
qc
so sometimes we've had sequences that
were cq 27 which failed
but we think that's probably because of
a library prep artifact or something
so we've had uh our um we've had
cq values as low as 21 coming from
campus not the isolation dorm from an
actual drum
we've had cqs as low as 21 from
wastewater all the way up to 37
38. thank you so much
dr kritikiyan and we have time for two
more questions were the automatic
samplers purchased
by this project or will you were you
able to borrow some
from the county and what kind of energy
source do they require
um all of them are battery operated we
didn't
um the county paid for us to pay them
for
their projects and the funding enabled
us to
buy our campus auto samplers
they are all battery operated and they
pick up time-weighted composites
so the county samples are flow weighted
but our campus ones are time-weighted so
full weighted is obviously better but
they're really expensive so we use the
water meter data and we use peppermild
model virus and others
for using the data quantitatively
so we typically don't use the um
wastewater campus data quantitatively we
use it qualitatively we only use the
isolation dorm
and the point loma data quantitatively
because
we use those for modeling but for just
building data they only want to know
yes or no we screen for three genes we
only consider it a positive
if all three genes in both the
replicates are amplified
um otherwise we call it inconclusive but
so far um
we've had um i guess
all of ours have been amplified in three
genes
in both the replicates we do n one and
two and e
for circle v2 we multiplex it our
qpcr is also miniaturized so we put in
much less quantity so we can scale it up
you know cost effectively and i guess
there was one that i see how sensitive
is your
surveillance um it is pretty sensitive
so we've
not missed any case except for four
cases but that was because the campus
um because the samplers did not pick up
a sample we get one in
our largest occupied building has about
650 students and we picked up one
asymptomatic case in that building as
well
thank you so much and our final question
we have time for
have you observed any inhibition with
the nanotrap
pre-concentration method and if so how
do you
did you overcome that um
if you're talking about pcr inhibition
we have not
encountered that so far um we do
homogenize our samples so there are
pretty big chunks of solids that go into
our sample so we do not let it sit
for a while and take the supernatant but
when we do dilution series as well as an
inhibition panel we
do not see it being significantly
inhibited
ironically we've had inhibitions from
our surface swap samples
based on the detergent or disinfectant
the person used to sanitize the school
desk but for wastewater
so far in all of the samples process
we've not seen significant enough
um cq value shift for us to flag it as
you know we cannot use this data
quantitatively
dr carrick can thank you so much for
your presentation today would you like
to provide any final comments for our
audience before we close
um nothing specific but feel free to
reach out
um if you have any additional questions
via email i'd be happy to answer them
well i want to thank you again for your
time and your important research
and presentation and we also want to
thank lab roots and our sponsor
sarah's nano sciences for underwriting
today's
educational webcast and before we go i
want to thank the audience
for joining us today and for their
interesting questions
questions we did not have time for today
and those submitted during the on-demand
period
will be addressed by our speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration
and this webcast can be viewed on demand
lab routes will alert you via email
it's available free play share that
email will see your colleagues
who may have missed today's live event
until next time
take care everyone be safe i had a quick
comment as well so
if we're also planning to release our
campus data as a preprint in the next
week or so so we're also happy to share
raw data for others who are interested
in looking
at the you know the campus data as well
as our point loma data so we're making
all of our
data as well as the entire workflow open
source so others would be able to
view and implement it
thank you so much dr carthy can and
again take care everyone bye-bye